هوت الليره اللبنانيه امام الدولار
الامريكي الى مستوى قياسي جديد حيث بلغ
سعر صرف الدولار 100 الف ليره في السوق
الموازيه بينما السعر الرسمي لصرف الدولار
مقابل الليره يبلغ 15 الف ليره كما حدد
مصرف لبنان سعرا اضافيا لصرف الدولار في
المداولات التجاريه عبر منصه صيرفه يبلغ
نحو 75 الف ليره هذا وياتي انهيار الليره
في ظل الازمه الاقتصاديه التي بدات منتصبه
منتصف عام 2019
وحولت اكثر من 80% من اللبنانيين الى
فقراء وفق منظمه الاسكوا
المصارف اللبنانيه بدات اضرابا مفتوحا عن
العمل وذلك احتجاجا على قرارات قضائيه
صدرت بحكه عدد منها جاء ذلك على خلفيه رفض
هذه البنوك تسديد الودائع بالعملات
الاجنبيه
وطالبت جمعيه المصارف بتصحيح ما وصفته
بالخلل في هذه القرارات كما دعت الجمعيه
السلطات الرسميه الى ايجاد حل شامل للقطاع
المالي يشار الى ان المصارف اللبنانيه
كانت قد اغلقت ابوابها لاكثر من اسبوعين
الشهر الماضي ثم عاودت عملها وذلك بعد
تلقيها وعودا لمعالجه الخلل في عمل القضاء
وفق قولها
وفي غضون ثلاث سنوات ونصف منذ بدايه
الازمه اللبنانيه خسرت العمله المحليه 98%
من قيمتها منذ بدء الانهيار الاقتصادي في
خليفه 2019 حيث اندلعت انتفاضه شعبيه
لبنانيه عابره للمناطق احتجاجا على ترد
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وفي
الرابع من اغسطس عام 2020 تسببا انفجار
مرفا بيروت في عواقب اقتصاديه كبيره
واقترب سعر الصرف من 9000 ليره وفي يونيو
عام 2021 صنف البنك الدولي ازمه لبنان
الاقتصاديه بين الاشد حده في العالم منذ
منتصف القرن التاسع عشر وتجاوز سعر الصرف
حاجز العشرين الف ليره استمرت العمله
اللبنانيه في خساره قيمتها لتتخطى في
فبراير الماضي عتبه 80 الف ليره لبنانيه
مقابل الدولار